every year 600 million people fly into
or from europe after a dip because of
the recession that staggering number is
again growing so how to accommodate them
in europe's already tight airspace
airspace run by air traffic controllers
of 28 eu states some of it subject to
military exclusion sometimes the
aircrafts fly zigzag and stack on
instead of direct roads and that's
because of
national uh supervisory
institutions and it's because of
military area that's on the ground and
so on and it would be by far better to
have a direct line it would cost less
for fuel it would save fuel and of
course it would save some emission at
the same time this kind of shows the
congestion air traffic controllers have
to unscramble a never-ending traffic
flow which according to new legislation
designed to modernize rationalize and
unify europe's airspace in an upgraded
single european sky leads to costs all
round including fares now in europe we
have
we do not have borders on the ground
but we have borders on the sky the
single european sky could be a very
very good
result for
for everybody not only for consumers but
there's resistance not least from
europe's 40 000 air traffic controllers
many fear for their jobs and that
centralized control of european airspace
blocks with reduced spending targets
over five years could compromise safety
sooner or later we will see that the
controllers will not be well trained
like like i said now there's such a
safety system around now for every state
every service provider a complete safety
system which is working safety is of
course the most important thing but the
safety increased a lot in
the
last period in
europe putting the single european sky
into flight has been and will continue
to be a torturous process meps are
hoping for majority support at the first
reading in plenary this week but on
final agreement they know they're in for
the long haul